[Musique]
oui
comme chaque matin c'est la prise
d'assaut
oc vous poussez vous vers le fond
une cinquantaine de villageois se ruent
dans le camion de ramassage
une heure de trajet les attend
ou
bien parmi eux m ou scène et son fils
reboot ils travaillent ensemble depuis
trois ans
on bosse
l'ambiance est détendue l'humeur joyeuse
difficile de croire que ces hommes se
dirige droit vers un enfer
[Musique]
nous sommes à l'est de l'île de java de
la ceinture de feu du pacifique
au coeur de la région la plus sismique
de la planète le kawah ijen et son lac
acide
allez on y va chaque jour ces hommes
descendent dans le cratère au milieu des
vapeurs toxiques pour extraire du ventre
de la terre un minerai couleur d'or le
soufre
passez la fumée s'incruste partout dans
notre corps ont tous ça c'est
irrespirable avait les yeux qui pleurent
[Musique]
je ne peux pas détester le volcan je
travaille ici tous les jours le kawah
ijen me donne il travaille et je le
remercie tous les jours pour ça
nous avons partagé le quotidien de ces
mineurs de père en fils pierre et
courageux c'est fort ça ne se plaignent
jamais de leurs conditions de travail
d'un autre âge
non journée commence pour les 350
mineurs du kawah ijen j'ai laissé mon
panier là bas
[Musique]
allez voir
première étape l'ascension du volcan
au coeur de la forêt 3 km de sentiers
escarpés pour atteindre le sommet du
cratère à 2400 mètres d'altitude
on ne va pas trop charger les paniers
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on garde encore
de la force pour les autres jours
il devrait pleuvoir aujourd'hui mais
j'espère que mon
salut toi ton est déjà ton premier
panier tous les mineurs se connaissent à
27 ans reboot et moins expérimenté que
les autres
ils appréhendent encore la descente dans
les entrailles du volcan
va prendre le chemin juste latine et
maintenant
vous voyez cette fumée qui sort de la
terre et bien ce sont les vapeurs de
soufre un simple lien et au téléthon
midi à sa porte en face à toronto
je me souviens la première fois que je
suis descendu et au dressage était mort
de trois
jeunes avaient peur de tomber
ou alors que les rocher se détache et
qu'il s'écroule sur moi
des mineurs avant salle aveugle
les fumées toxiques brûle de sentiers
déjà instable
[Musique]
elles proviennent des profondeurs du lac
le plus acide de la planète sont nos se
réchauffe au contact du magma et se
transforme en vapeur chargé de soufre
grâce à ces canalisations
elle remonte à la surface et va ensuite
se liquéfier et durcir au contact de
l'air froid
[Musique]
ce sont ces cristaux que les mineurs
doivent détaché à coups de barre de fer
l'air est irrespirable
le mélange de dioxyde de soufre et
d'acide chlorhydrique leur brûle les
poumons
avec un foulard comme seule protection
les deux hommes a racheté à mains nues
les blocs de soufre encore brûlant
ya aînés blais l'année c'est vraiment
brûlant
il faut attendre un peu et surtout les
laisser reposer
par un départ
les mineurs ne faiblissent pas il s'agit
de remonter le plus de minerai possible
sans trop s'attarder
ici on manque vraiment d'oxygène et les
gars sont très dangereux
si on traîne trop après on aura plus de
force pour porter nos paniers c'était
qui est un peu tôt il y a vingt ans
quatre hommes sont morts ici au bord du
lac une bulle de gaz géante est remonté
à la surface avant d'éclater intoxiquant
les mineurs présents dans le cratère
[Applaudissements]
matroska mais reboot ont collecté près
de 70 kg de soufre chacun ils doivent
maintenant les remonter à la surface
[Musique]
400 m de dénivelé le long du précipice
enveloppé par le nuage
je suis crevée ouais moi aussi j'ai
envie de dormir
aucune étude n'a jamais été donnée sur
les conséquences du soufre sur la santé
des mineurs mais certains symptômes sont
évidents fatigue vieillissement
prématuré et carences en calcium liés à
l'inhalation quotidienne de soufre
qu'on la fumée très épaisse ça m'arrive
de mettre un masque à gaz mais la
plupart du temps j'utilise juste mon
foulard
j'arrive mieux à respirer comme ça le
problème c'est que le tissu est imbibé
de soufre et ça attaque la racine des
docks et scame à un simple et
moi aussi j'avais déjà des problèmes de
dents avant et ça s'est encore aggravé
avec ce travail
[Musique]
les deux hommes ont pris plus d'une
heure pour rejoindre le sommet du
cratère
il reste encore trois kilomètres à
parcourir pour livrer leur premier
panier de la journée
[Musique]
épuisés ils font une pause avant d'aller
chercher leurs derniers chargements 1 m
y a pas main
tout lundi
il est
là
des
témoins ont fait une petite place
tu peux nous faire de riz s'il te plaît
l'e shop est tenu par huit ya au fil des
ans elle est devenue leur soutien leur
confidente
c'est comme une mère pour nous elle nous
réconforte
ça nous fait du bien parfois elle nous
fait même crédit et on peut la régler le
lendemain quand on a été payé
je suis une des seules femmes au milieu
de tous ces hommes et ça ne m'ennuie pas
en plus ce sont de bons clients
la cantine c'est leur récréation le seul
répit dans leurs journées infernales
j'ai commencé à 7 heures au pied du
volcan et j'ai fini à 10 euros ou du
cratère
c'était vraiment dur soit
vous n'aimeriez pas que la mine met en
place des machines pour remonter le
soufre et vous soulager un peu les
paquets et
surtout pas rater les machines débarque
on est foutu
ouais on sera tous au chômage ont ainsi
été nommés co
de toute façon aucune machine ne peut
tenir dans le volcan ses traits
corrosifs or
au fond du cratère les installations
résistent mal le soufre s'enflamme de
gigantesques incendies se déclarent
plusieurs fois par jour
[Musique]
il ya un feu il faut intervenir vite
pour que les canalisations ne brûle part
sinon c'est toute la production de
soufre qui risquent de s'évaporer
cet homme qui se risque au plus près de
la fournaise cebu do you know le frère
aîné de ma trousse n son travail le plus
dangereux de la mine réparer les tuyaux
cerné par les vapeurs toxiques
ça va on fait bien attention et suivez
moi par là
[Musique]
il ya des fuites vous voyez il faut
mettre du ciment pour colmater les trous
pour que la fumée ne se disperse pas
au bout d'une demi heure le feu et enfin
maîtriser les mineurs peuvent reprendre
le travail
salut mes frères comment ça va
quand est-ce que tu rentres chez toi
et sois
ce soir
avant boudineau était lui aussi porteurs
de soufre mais à cinquante six ans à
bout de force il s'est reconverti pour
devenir technicien de maintenance
bas ne les voyait ses cicatrices la ja
et mes amis
ça faisait vraiment très mal ça saigne
et à chaque fois que je portais les
paniers
ma famille surtout ma femme mon souhait
d'arrêter ce travail à cause de mon dos
kecka il se faisait vraiment du souci et
alain
quand il était porteur vous dieu nous
gagner plus d'argent mais avec ce
travail il continue à faire vivre toute
sa famille
[Musique]
le salaire reste l'unique motivation des
porteurs de soufre du kawah ijen
[Musique]
tu as rapporté 68 kg
pour les mineurs c'est l'heure de la
pesée du soulagement à 50,3 en maths
roussel tient encore la forme ça te fait
70 kg madrie seine les mineurs sont
payés au poids après chaque livraison le
tarif 5 centimes le kg de soufre
lusine leur fixe un prix d'achat les
mineurs l'accès tout pas et s'ils ne
sont pas d'accord ils peuvent aller
travailler ailleurs
d'après moi c'est un très bon salaire
ça suffit pour vivre au village
ma trousse n a gagné à peine 8 euros
pour 140 kg de soufre ramasser avec 200
euros par mois les mineurs gagne deux
fois plus que le salaire moyen denaisien
je suis vraiment content doit encore
grâce à ses deux paniers je vais pouvoir
faire vivre ma famille
et surtout payer l'école de mes enfants
à catania si on travaillait dans les
rizières il nous faudrait quatre jours
pour regagner ce qu on touche ici en une
seule journée
les 300 leaders collecte une quinzaine
de tonnes de soufre par jour
il est expédié chaque soir à l' usine au
pied du volcan pour être transformé
il servira au blanchiment du sucre à la
fabrication d'allumettes ou même à la
production de cosmétiques
lusine revend le soufre transformer 70
centimes d'euros le kilo treize fois
plus que ce qu'elle donne aux mineurs
[Musique]
il est 18h les mineurs rentrent dans
leur village à une vingtaine de
kilomètres du kawah ijen
[Musique]
parmi ces enfants du village les deux
fils cadet de matrot scène ils sont
conscients des risques que leur père
prend tous les jours pour faire vivre la
famille
du coup j'ai peur qu'ils tombent dans le
fun
parce que rare au prat cas cela me rend
triste que le voir travail du prix
d'ailleurs mais qui
rentrent le soir a constaté fait un
massage pour qu'il aille mieux
je travaille bien à l'école ou pour
mieux réussir que lui c'est
à la maison les deux porteurs peuvent
enfin souffler comme chaque soir battre
hossein s'offrent un petit remontant
[Musique]
ça me donne des forces
on va pas tu veux manger c'est prêt
nous vous remercions à la pour ce retard
mais trop scène regrette toujours que
son fils ait quitté l'école à présentes
pour leur région non le chômage touche
la moitié des habitants où tout
je ne voulais pas
qu'il arrêtait sa décrue très entière
alors il était à bali pour chercher du
travail tu parles bien sûr il n'a rien
trouvé m'a rejoint la bid et maintenant
je veux que la génération de leaders ça
va être très bien tapissez un banga je
suis fier de
ce qu'ils avancent que quand à lissac à
kétou
thomas aurait peut-être que dieu éloigne
d'un jeu seraient mineures comme tout
cas ça démissionne territoriales parce
qu'elle est brave docteur ce métier
qu'ils veulent
au reboot ce qui compte c'est l'honneur
la dignité des mineurs du volcan
réputées être les hommes les plus forts
de l'île de java
des forçats des temps modernes qui
refusent d'être considérés comme les
esclaves du kawah ijen
[Musique]